Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE, radical
Republican congresswoman. She spoke at one
of the Trump rallies. At this point, who even
knows which one it is? She is not even pretending
anymore. She is fully doing the replacement theory
thing. This is the white replacement theory or
great replacement theory. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Joe Biden's 5 million illegal
aliens are on the verge of replacing
you. Replacing your jobs and replacing
your kids in school and coming from all
over the world. They're also replacing
your culture, and that's not great for America.
Speaker 1: For a long time, we knew that these
folks were pushing this idea, but they still had
to sort of pretend not to or they had the couch
it in different language, or they had to figure
out a way to make the case that it's not horribly
xenophobic and in many cases racist. They've
given up on that. And the idea here there's kind
of two layers to this white replacement theory,
great replacement theory. The idea is the left.
Democrats, Marxists, Communists. Like, fill
in the blanks. Right. Whoever whoever it is
that they claim is doing this stuff. The
George Soros. Right. Fill in the blanks.
They are they are actively trying to
bring people into the United States,
including through undocumented immigration.
In order to replace the current demographic
realities of the United States. Another way to say
it is the left is deliberately, by any possible
means that that they can think of trying to change
the racial and ethnic makeup of the United States
in order to then what whatever, you know, win
elections, change the culture or whatever that
that's the idea of it. And it's often kind
of the undertone to a lot of the reporting
on shows like Tucker Carlson and others about
immigration and the debate around immigration.
That's what it is. There's many issues with it,
but one of the issues that exists with that is
that if you start to believe what Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is saying. You start to justify violence,
attacks, domestic terrorism, whatever, against
Americans, against the country, against leftists,
because you believe that that is what they are
doing. You start to believe there's a concerted
effort to root out white people generally
is the way that it goes. And when Marjorie
Taylor GREENE says this stuff, it is a form
of stochastic terrorism that could incite or
encourage exactly those types of attacks. So this
is extraordinarily dangerous rhetoric. You know,
you're never going to charge her over it, as
we've talked about before, whether it's Tucker
doing it or whoever. Not going to charge them for
it. Certainly not under the current law. And I'm
not necessarily even arguing the law should be
changed. I mean, we have free speech and there's
limits, but they're quite loose. Okay. But we have
to understand this for what it is. It is painting
an untrue picture of the goals of those left
wingers that they talk about. And it's dangerous,
it's xenophobic, it's racist. It's all of these
things. The crowd, it resonates with the crowd.
But they don't even really understand how they're
being manipulated and sort of directed by it. And
they're not going to stop because they're doing
really well, pushing exactly this sort of stuff.